all season long
in this great
game of baseball you hear the phrase
well there's always tomorrow
that does not really apply to the
chicago cubs today a legit cy young
candidate he or bower or maybe degrom
but second in the league in era he was
fabulous he was outstanding and like i
said in the open he has got to be
really good early in the game he's got
to be efficient keep his pitch count
down
and the righty deals and a swing and a
miss and a good start for you darvish
this is the pitch that put him on the
map that's a change up right there that
is not the shoot though i thought that
might be more of a split change but
that's more the circle change right
there
22 year old sixto sanchez
a very hard thrower yeah this guy throws
exceptionally hard he is going to be
special uh you saw it his first four or
five starts he was virtually unhittable
a little erratic the last couple of
starts
a little bit low oh no it's in there for
called strike three
will little little bit late rizzo didn't
like the call
i think kazon had it as a strike it was
just the call was late to me
yeah this pitch is virtually unhitter
ball this ball starts off the inside
corner tails back rorber a left-handed
batter
swag and a miss 100 or a hundy as the
kids might say
you're always going to get the nod to
the pitcher the first time around this
is the first time the cubs are seeing
him as well
scoreless game third inning here's ian
happ
here's a little looper shallow left
field base hit falling in front of
dickerson
hat sounded like a broken bat
it went to the opposite field
the cubs have a man on and anthony rizzo
coming up
only one infielder on the left side of
second that's rojas the shortstop
anthony lines one toward left field but
right there is dickerson backing up and
making the catch no runs the game's
first hit and a man left looking good
for 6-0 through three were scoreless the
marlins and the cubs game two of the
nationally wildcard series now the
marlins are threatening after the single
and they hit batter wyland's trying to
win and advance
on the ground baez cody
rizzo
6-4-3
exactly what darvish and the cubs needed
birdie ended up at third on the play but
now there are two down darvish coming
back 2-2
swag and a mess strike three he got him
on a curveball a marlin squander a first
and second no out opportunity
so just the way the uh marlins top of
the fourth inning began the first two
men reached for the cubs a scoring
chance with chris bryant sanchez
swaying and aligner caught back to
second and they don't double them off
bryant reaching there and lines out one
down first and second no score bottom of
the fourth here's jason hayward
here it comes hayward it's a line drive
base hit right field
contrast had to hold up he's going to
try to score here comes the throw to the
plate and contreras is going to be out
at the plate
advancing to third is schwarber on the
single by hayward contreras i believe
ran through a stop sign at third close
but matt joyce comes up
one two three perfect one hop that's
great execution right there by his
dangerous right-handed batter it starts
with a slightly open stance
rests the bat on his back shoulder then
elevates it as sixto comes set
the o2 pitch is popped in the air right
field playable for joyce he's under it a
couple of steps toward the line makes
the catch and sixth goes out of the
inning
one and one on rojas scoreless tie fifth
inning here's the pitch of swinging a
drive out toward the alleyway and left
center and that ball is going to bang
off the bullpen door rojas to second and
he slides in just in time ahead of the
tag by david bodie
and the cubs may take a look at the
video here it was a pretty close play
rojas with a head first slide into
second and right now it's a double out
wow
and rojas
retired so now the bases are loaded and
an opportunity for kyle schwarber two
outs fifth inning a 2-2 to schwarber and
a fly ball to left
dickerson ranging to his right two hands
on it and that will do it the cubs have
stranded runners in each of the last
four innings seven
in all including three here in the fifth
two down nobody on garrett cooper the
batter darvish ready here comes the 2-2
that one hammered to left darvish with
schwarber back there looking and that
one is gone
garrett cooper will touch them all as he
deposits it into the bleachers
and the marlins have jumped out one to
nothing
on the blast by cooper how about that
just the third marlins head meanwhile
rojas will be walked intentionally and
this will put two men on for magnarise
sierra
look at this sierra with a base hit
brenson around third in the plate and he
will score
they go with the intentional walk and
magnori sierra delivers and the marlins
are up 2-0
two-nothing merlin's eighth inning
oh is the umpire calling him back
will little is saying
they put his elbow into it and guessing
david ross might get thrown out here
that's a very crucial point in this game
you hardly ever see that actually called
by a home plate umpire and i don't know
that i would have called it right there
to be honest with you yeah with hayward
at second now there are two outs
and jason kipnis
yeah the bottom feeders trying to
advance
two and two kinsler deals
swing and a miss got him and it's over
and the marlins are headed to the
division series
as they beat the cubs two nothing the
final here
and they advance to the ds a two to
nothing win at wrigley field this
afternoon and a sweep